good day everyone my name is jorge
douglas
the idea thanks first of all for
your interest in being here
the idea is to present the espai plan in a
python development uni with some
different ideas let's say what you may
be used to
not the idea  make a presentation if not
a talk we have a debate guide but
from now on we invite those who want to join us in the development to
ask to interrupt at all times
those who want to accompany us in
the development by entering my pipe plan
dotcom
and they enter with their linkedin user
and they will be able
not only  create an account that they can
use later but follow the
development that we are going to do
and
we have places
where the login should be born
while we access it is that I tell you
a little about pipe plan I think everything is
so familiar with a jupiter
notebooks then  we are going to use the
analogy with as a point of reference
to understand similarities and differences
that one may have about  re the other one
in what you have already registered and this one
on the home page down here in the
tutorial section there is one
called pay data presentation and there they will be
able to if you click there they will open and
well there are things  that are but assembled and
there are others that we are going to put together
during the presentation so that they have good access
in that it looks like how
pipeline differs in relation to a peter notebook
the fundamental difference is that the
repository of the code that we are going to
write stops  to be a written text
and it becomes contained in nodes and
then if one does not apologize more before
we all move forward someone could access
give that wants to join us we wait for it
well
in the upper part on the right they have
no 21 dragged a node and the node  it is the
container of the code
and we drag a node you
will see that it has no attributes if
among its properties a title where
one describes there is a difference between what
can be a halter type tool
ix or c  Any tool where the
workflows, the paths, the
calculation steps are specific, in this case what
we want is for our code
to be understandable so that someone
who can read it can understand it
conceptually before going into the
detail of what it does in  each
step then the first thing we do is
create a variable in this case for the
example that we are going to develop after
we have tried to be as general as
possible and given the economic context
we live in it calls the exchange rate so if
the variable that  we are going to create
also has an id
so it is like the air is the name of
the global variable that we are going to be able to
use in the rest of
our programming
and then other attributes that we are going to
see over time in this
case  the units are things that we are going to
point to after the second the
second tab allows us to
directly access where we are going to encode
if it is the is where the  code is written and
here we are going to ask lukas to give us an
example that is not easy
to follow for everyone let's say define another
variable
and then an operation of one over
another
we are going to execute it with the console if
we have a little space
there it is  well
and in the console we see we have the
result of a and the result of the
product of a orb
and another other way of evaluating that same
way that will bring us a little more
information is by pressing control if it
exists and there they are showing us a
little  more information and what type of
variables we have what is the
console result and with the result of the
variable that we are executing if this
when
the program becomes a little more complex it
also allows us to make a profile and
they will understand why  this the
profile not only of the variable but all
the way good since we are
talking about it unlike jupiter
where one can command to execute what
you just wrote or all  or up to that
point in the pipeline,
the result of this programming is a
code tree where, when
executing one of those nodes, it
automatically understands all its
presidencies and only the presidencies are
executed, that is, one does not execute everything
up to there, but everything that is strictly
it is necessary to produce that result
and then that allows many things to coexist within a
programming environment
and that they are activated or not
according to the result that we are or what
we are doing
well
the programming environment that is the
code editor is  the complete one is to say
we can have all the
included kelpers and they will help us well
as in any idea
and in this case
we have the pandas kelpers
to write any function
later we are going to address the issue of
installing libraries that type  of
things and let's go but we're going step by step
we're fine so far any questions
ok
what's up we're with reflexes of
integ  ral
and if they connect to the phone
no
good then with patience
the third tap refers to the
documentation that is to say it is so important
when one is creating the code that it not
only works well but that we
understand it we understand the
program code we understand the concepts of what
what are we doing then, especially
if one thinks that those who are going to use these
tools are people who are not
necessarily programmers,
then it is a very good initiative to
include that code in that explanation
inside a notebook
and in the same way that is  captured
here they are
going to change the connection also
well we are moving forward anyway let's
show an example of how to document
then let's suppose that we would like to
document how the type of changes is defined
let's say
and take a bit of code to give
a bit of history  of how many zeros
our currency had a few years ago
the third way to evaluate these
nodes is  When we double click on them,
what we are going to see is a very very simple result,
obviously it is the product of what
we did previously, but it will
also allow us to explore the
documentation that we have just created,
if for some reason we would like to see
what that refers to.  number
and we have all that we have just
explained as concepts that
support this calculation step and on the other hand
we can return as always any
variable that we are evaluating return to the
diagram through
that same thing was you read well well
ok
the other objective of pay  The plan in this
approach to end users is to
facilitate those first those first
steps that are taken in programming that
teach us how the basic concepts work, the
basic syntax,
then something that we are experiencing
is working very well, the first
steps that we have taken in  the creation of
wizards that assist
elementary things in this case the link
with a data source  os of external
such local we are going to choose a
a data source a csb
makes a previous interpretation of
what the columns are the types
if finally we define
if we are going to keep some index index
or we
do not have a name that data source
if we are already in conditions  to
visualize it by double-clicking on
the variable we will now see the
panda that we have just read rendered
as a table
on this band
the idea is not to abound simply to know
that this table that we are seeing is a
form that speaks to you, that is, it cannot define
many  attributes on that table
regarding how you want to visualize that
data and those those attributes are well
obviously preserved for future
evaluations so from now on
every time we go back to that sales node
its formation will be that the lyon and cost
have the peso sign  and
so it could be with good a series
of training parameters then you
will be able to freely explore it
well we will start u  Using the wizards,
the first thing we are going to do is calculate
a unit price. If we have a
sales column, we have a quantity column,
so we say how the
revenue to ban ki-moon is actually,
we have a price and we are going to get the sale,
perfectly fine.
then we are going to calculate a calculation of
a new field that is the total revenue
is the quantities sold
multiplied by
the sale price
what is interesting about this is that
through weezer the code of pandas was already created
the code of yes  in this case it
is pandas, that is to say, someone who did not know
anything simply by interacting with
the help and realized that for God
to degenerate a new field I have to
tell him what I want that
field to be called and that the result thus invoked each
one of the  columns are the ones
I want to operate on so that was the
starting point to let it
take off
if in that case well obviously if
we evaluate that node it is data frame
what  e has in its last column the total
prevent that we have just defined
in the same way
what are we going to do now what are we going to
calculate the sales in pesos we assume
that the sales were originally in
dollars what we are going to do is
multiply it by the type  of change that
we just created in the perfect field type node
then we are going to generate a new node
a new calculation step and we are going to
indicate if you
do not
click or control click on the
previous node to refer to the
previous variable if you  Look, I already
wrote here sales that the name of
this variable
and then we are going to make the sales that
we had in dollars and we are going to
multiply them by the exchange rate
and to bring the exchange rate variable
what I did was press control and
make it  clicking on the node that has a type of
change like this
in the code directly puts me in the
air of the variables
always each each variable ends with
a definition of rizal which is the
r  The result of its evaluation is what it
will show when you double-click that
variable if you look at the
arrows well obviously they are created
automatically to indicate the
dependency between the variables if now you are
crazy
and we have the new column well now we are going
to clean a  little this and
select some columns
we are going to use again another another
weezer that allows us to do that that is going
to allow the user
and understand how it is done to select
the column
we are seeing the most basic steps of
all after having well
sophisticated applications generate everything  this but it is
so that the others understand that we
need to do the first final
steps then we are going to select from
all the columns and we are going to keep a
few for what we want to
do
and if you look
here the code for the
selection of the columns appeared  columns
automatically
then well the next step is how
we are going to assume that we is our
file  I have sales and we want to
pivot that data, slice in and
i' sing on that data, so what we are
going to do is define the indexes of
that data frame
and in that case we go
directly with double click
or controller and we have the data  frame that
the pse without having added any
line of code in relation to how to
automatically render for the plan
interprets that according to the data frame that is
indexed it will not allow us to pivot
with that data
we have the dimensions below
and see that
for the different dimensions that  it is
open
in the same way, it does not include some
totals or visualize them as a graphic tablet
and graph that
are unquoted, it
is linked, so any
navigation that one makes on one of the
dimensions has the impact on the
graphic visualization,
we could filter some elements
and I am going to
do or drill down
to understand how it is composed
and explore the different dimensions,
note that all of this  it is native and
automatically interpreted in the
end user he did not have to write
any additional code beyond creating the
data frame to be able
to explore
the data that was coming in
well
we are fine so
far well now a quick survey those who
know about pandas raise your hand
in a country
exa right there
are very few
well ex array is a
payton library that is also under the
umbrella in a focus that basically
what is interesting is that the
matrices with which one operates the
dimensions are not dimensions one or two
or  three but they are named dimensions they
are called name arrays so
one stops talking about
dimension 1 2 3 again and starts talking about
time starts talking about d
product regions or
whatever the dimensions that characterize the
data set with which  we are working
and that makes the
matrix operations have a bit
different character they are not exactly the same
as what one would expect from in a p  aís
so we are going to see a little the
differences between one and the other anticipating
that this was going to happen
let's say that there were many people who
knew about pandas and never but not
so much about exa wright we prepared this case
and then if one opera we are going to think
we have one  a two-by-two matrix in
ex array
and we are going to make it operate with another
two-by-two matrix
we go first on a country
then one does one for the other being
that the dimension the dimensions are
equal of the two matrices in a plane
have  a problem in solving that
operation and where it is going to be is the sum of
elements by the element that
corresponds to the same cell and j
in next array
that same matrix
requires first of all the definition of
the dimensions that is to say here we not only
have the same elements  of data
but also we have indicated that
one of the dimensions is going to be
regions and the second is going to be
sales channels and then in that case if one
evaluates that matrix one is going to find  r
so now the dimensions are ex
explicit and we have the north and the channel
a and b
the addition operation is exactly the
same and it works in this case
exactly the same as in a country
evaluate it with double click so what remains is
there in the tags or not
and then  there we can see the sum that
we just made of 1 and if we see
we go back to the diagram
the sum of the other double click
on the week axis 1 there is already 2
and on the other it is
the dimensions have a name and
yet the operations are exactly the
same I think  they have ex array ex arrays
solves two things that are very
important 1 of the alignment of the
arrays that is, when one works
with dimensions that are named, one does not
have to worry about operating with
arrays based on their shapes, already
knowing that the dimensions that are the
themselves is responsible for aligning the
arrays to be able to do the
operation so that the same dimensions
operate on the same dimensions in
one and in another and the other thing that  What it has
is broadcasting and interpreting
as scalar every dimension
that is not repeated in the other matrix,
that is, if one makes a sum of let's
think, for example, of something that is
open in channels and regions and will
multiply it by something  that it is open in
channels in time there are two two
variables that two dimensions that do not
coincide in one and in another then one
works for the other and vice versa as a
scale with respect to the dimension that does not
contain an example to be clearer than
my explanation
let's see an example
if we are going to make the product of the two
and let's see the broadcasting as we
had not foreseen
in which part we are not doing the step
of payment we go with the order that
this nest has on whether we have to explain what
it is doing and what  we are
showing adorers that if we do if
we put the matrix in a country behind and after
we put the data array matrix
in a country the result of the sum of
both will change but the king is
it is not going to change because the dimensions are
so called
the alignment with the dimensions of
automatic so we do not have to
go indicating that in exchange for the order
of that matrix the example to
demonstrate what I spoke before the
alignment function
let's do it we do it quickly what  What we did
was the transpose of del rey 2
and now more to the same sum that we had
done before but instead of the original
we are going to use the response matrix
and we are going to do the same operation with
data rate that also has a
transpose operation
then  look at the result of the
mazda operation that was transposed
between 1 and the original that is the
first of all that does not change if they are
exactly the same instead in the other
and the results are not the same yes
because what was dimension was not
transformed  in two for one and for the
other and then the operation is different from
the second example again instead of
writing it
and now what we are going to assume is that
qu  We are going to add a new dimension in
the case of although the matrix is ​​going to be
2 x 2 in the case of data array we are
varying a different dimension before
we had religions and sales channels
now what we want to add is a type
of item
so the  The expected result in the
afternoon was going to be to add a third
dimension because it is detecting that
there is a new dimension. Instead, the
data rate in the matrix will continue to
be two-dimensional,
that is, in this case, we are waiting
with a node that has two dimensions.  and
another that has two dimensions and one of
them does not match the result is the
union of the dimensions of the two
it is not our result to have three
dimensions in this case channels
regions and item type if we had
to do that in a country we would have  to
see the matrices of two by two I
will give you two by adding a third
dimension to be able to operate but it is
quite more cumbersome this is solved
automatically by alineam  ient and
broadcasting
then we are making there
the product of a 2 by 2 matrix that
is indexed by regions and channels
because the sums are good if the sum is added by
adding another
that has dental regions and regions and
then not pieces
you are doing it with a country
we are also going to do well
ok
in the cube that we have now it has three
dimensions in this
well that is the basics to understand
what this raid is about
if its fundamental concepts are
that alignment and broadcasting
now well ex array has and this already  it is
a contribution of pipe plan on ex
array it has a peculiarity that is
when the dimensions are defined
through links, that is, the name of
that dimension and the coordinates in
that dimension, then we could be
operating with two variables that have the
same dimension  which is time but
nevertheless its coordinates are
defined for different moments of
time, one for a particular year
and  another for another and the operation between
both, that is, the intersection of
coordinates of one with the other would be null
and therefore the result would be null
then what
and ask the user to guarantee the
integrity of the coordinates
throughout a large model  is is too much
then what it does for the plan to
solve that difficulty is to create
something called indices which is not an object
itself but is a pandas index
in its definition but basically what it
does at the same time defines the name
of the  dimension and coordinates and that
is used throughout the model,
that is, throughout our programming environment,
so in this way we
guarantee that whenever a
variable has a definition of time,
the horizon of the variables coincides,
so when operating in  results we
simplify what happens when
we originally work with data rate
in the first node that we have up here
we had put
there type joins types of types of  items and
now what we are going to do is
add one to a data array that
has type 2 3 4 and 5 there the only
element they share
is type 2 so if we do the sum
of both
and evaluate
what we are going  let's see that the only type of
haiti that this matrix is ​​going to have is
type 2 it is the information of the other
types 1, 3 and 4 that we had, we lost it and
why because not here but with
something that it had in its definition of coordinates
less less elements so this
is something characteristic of c's array
we want to solve here and that is why
the way to do it is through an
index so in that case we
will define an index called type
and whose definition if you look at that is  a
panda index
and a list of the values ​​that it has
that is explicit in a certain way one could
be doing a reading of a
data source and keeping the
unique values ​​that define our dimension
explain in poets 10 lucas the
next step is u  use our own function
that we developed in by plan we
call them take what it does is
align these
this dimension that has
some items in one and others in others
this new index that we just created
that contains the set of both
that function  we call take
where we pass the same operation that
we had done before which was this
here I am going to indicate
what index I want to transform into the
index that has just been created
that is going to be authentic as it was here
I want that to be now type just
created
I do  the sum of both
and now in the array when I see the
types it contains all
all the pipe plan libraries they
have been released they are on github if you
look for pipeline exa rail you will
find them so they are the definition of
all these maya functions that are
explicit  here inside and you can see your
code
well
as we continue lucas
we were to the model that we have well
then to build what we have seen
so far is the  basic steps say
let's review the code we create it within
nodes the nodes are in general either a pan
data frame or an exhale object and the
dimensions are defined through its
index so we are now going to see
applications as we suppose that
this logic had evolved a
we have little more than the calculations made there
how we create one the same as we create a
user interface and how we
share it so that it is a
consumable application for an end user what we are
going to do now
then in this case well we have dale
in this case what  that this action is
basically to read the same csb that we have read
before what is done is to transform it
add ize by some dimensions
the unit cost is obtained the unit sales
the total cost
is calculated here it is calculated the unit price is taken
in this part what  What is being done is
projecting the price for a discount policy
to finally calculate the revenue, the
margin
and finally we do  s a workshop
here on projected sales what is
being done is to introduce an input that
the user can customize
where we can choose different
scenarios to highlight sales
we have a low scenario, a medium one
and a more optimistic one
and where we can load the
percentage of  growth of these
home sales we have preloaded for example
that for the wolf it is 1 percent for
every month for medium 2 and for high
today sales are being projected with
the medium scenario
another of the functionalities that
pipe land has is the introduction  of
interactive elements within the
diagram or within interfaces that
allow the end user not to have to
go around
getting into the code and here changing
the word medium for another, but for
example we could create
a selector that says automatically chosen scenario
when we create this type
of element  which is the decision that we
use for this type of
case we were created with a function
particular pipeline that is called a selector
and in there we can pass it what
values ​​we want that selector to
have
I am going to indicate that I want it to have
the market scenarios that we have
created here
and this to this element what I can
do is
show  a more friendly way
which of the three which of the three
I want to choose for example if I wanted
hi instead of medium I choose hyde and now I
can go to the definition and replace
while in the middle
with a direct reference to this
element
next to the I to stay  with the value
that it has
is that reader
when we make an interface it can be
applied better to be able to see the selector
recapitulating extracts then we
have basically three elements
we have input data tables that are
going to be seen in yellow here we have
calculation steps and we have selectors then
with  those three joke elements let's
build a a help
a UI
then the UI creation
it is also
with a drag and drop process
if in that case we are going to create a
new interface
and where you are going to basically have a
divisible canvas and where we can
add or configure the layout
as we want it to work the first thing
we are going to do is bring  the diagram
because basically the elements of
arama are the ones that are going to allow us to
build what we want to do
here I am going to divide the plinth
vertically so I could drag
elements from the diagram so for
example it could bring me the
market growth table that we have seen
that it was  editable
I am not going to configure it so that it can be
visited
below I am going to bring the selector that
we just created from the stage
and here it could bring me the
projected sales for example
you could see it with a line graph
and finally the herd below
it  I am also going to bring one of
the indices to be able to filter
we have negative sales but
I don't know what happened there you gave a lot  The
discounts are
not the objective of analyzing the
numbers today
and we are going to put that our cool one
and it is automatically interactive
I can see choosing a scenario and that
scenario when choosing will impact it and
will force the recalculation and
updating of any variable that
depends on this other one
or if I change one of the growth parameters
the same thing is going to happen
and the most interesting thing is how
this goes from fast to production in serve or
how I can share this application
that we just created
then one of the options that  I have
there is to be if they were in an environment
where it is installed and where we share
our space with many users
we can share it among those users and
if not we can also share it with
an external link
and if they notice we will open a new one
or you will publish it
if you want the phone it's not very big
but it
takes our banal twitter
account our twitter account on twitter.com
plan we are there they publish  Do the link and if
they click on that link they will directly
access the application that
we have just created
and they will be able to start interacting with
it
the kernel long each instance has
a different channel which allows
each one to be running
different scenarios  interacting with variables
different forms of these parameters
each one can be putting what they
want and the result is going to be
let's open a taxi so
this is what I see a user who
accessed the link that we sent
so notice that moving to production
did not require or  a line of code
literally
we are now going to see a
little more elaborate applications so that you have an
idea of ​​what this looks like when you do
things a little more seriously they are demos they
are not final products but well demos
a little more elaborated
by plan
us  we use it to do
various things
let's see talking now let's
also know with the user if they
entered havana for talking to
us  Others we use to do data
analytics to make some
machine learning application good budgeting
business planning
simulation scenario simulation optimization and management control
of companies let's say let's
see something called probably
more familiar to you let's see
a machine learning application is
created  also these series of menus
also easily to be able to navigate
the different ones just as one is
generating to show different
parts of our model of what we have
created
well I will tell a little place well this is
basically a demo that you have a
thousand loans of which  they are
classified as they have been paid well they
are not paid badly and based on that we try to
train a machine learning model
to predict
if a future client who was granted
a loan is going to make a good standard
so the first thing we had put together
was  first an exploration of the data
where we see graphically how it is
composed and  This data set that we have just
downloaded is
this this interface that we are seeing
now the table on the left is a
native pivot table of the tool that
we can filter
and the filters that we make will
also be applied to the rest of the
graphs that are  natives of pipe land
and below here we have a graph
of plot lic
the implementation of the graphs of 10
direct copy is copied and pasted as it
would be done with in jupiter notebook and the
only thing that we change is that we use our
own function that is called  plot
but to render the html that he generates
the blondie object
I was wondering last night why we didn't use bokeh we
already have homework to start with
incorporate the forest
these are graphs that show
some of the attributes that had
data & how they are all distributed in
these cases
and now if we can move on to the training part
here we take three different more classic methods it
is a classification problem
then the  We choose random forest
logistic regression and caution night bages
and based on the quick training that
we did we obtain these metrics.
Let's show how we go from here from one of
these metrics to see in the
calculation model where this was calculated because
each of these elements we are
seeing this  it is a variable within
our programming logic we go to
the one you want you can always
drop down here
and go
an option is it says wind airam if it is going
to take us exactly the place where
what we are seeing is being calculated
in our code  that
result that variable if you see
here
although it is a demo as I said before it already
has another body how
the code is structured
if I did not think about this in Jupiter we
will not have a notebook of 300 400 lines here
however let's go let's go still higher
that yes
let's go in  to the navigation it is gray that
then we have a module that has the
cleaning of the data the
exploratory analysis the or  another where we make the
machine learning classification and on the
other hand the predictions if
our code already begins to take another other
another form
then if we enter machine learning
we will see what we have separated the
data and the original data from
normalized data and each of these variables
if one double-clicks to see
that any calculation space could
say well let's see this is not necessary to
create a help and one cannot go
inspecting each one of those
calculation steps and see the result it generates and
that as a graph like  table like what we
saw in our first step
separate the data
separates the training data with the
data to you and finally we have here
our three mechanisms are structured if
one enters one of them
there yes we already effectively see the
training part in this case  we use that
chain as free between as a
training library ok
let's continue
these are the
training results they are not  very good but it was
a quick training
and finally here we have the application
for what could be a tool
for a bank that would like to anticipate
if at the moment of granting the loan
if one
a taker of subtractions is going to pay or not
then we have to have  a tablet
that is interactive where
the person from the bank can
fill in the assumptions
and from the parameters define the
credit rating when the
methodology or how much is the maximum that
we will be able to grant
with a certain probability of recovery
then here finally from the
training  what we did before what
we are doing is calculating if with
these parameters of this loan if the
random forest would approve if it has more than
100 percent it would try to approve it and
for the others also in this case the
three are not saying yes
and on the right we have  in the event that
it was not proven, could you tell us
what amount to add would prove to raise the mo  So
if the 3 100 approving
the random forest there, for example, it no
longer approves 10,000, it is telling me that
the maximum it could give is 3,500,
so if another 3,500,
the three methods are doing well with
a policy, for example, if there are two
methods  that they approve another loan for me,
the people at the bank could make a decision
in real time based on the training
that we finally finished below, we have
some metrics to assume a bit of the
analysis that are very technical, the
analyst should not be seeing them
but they do the demo
and  another example of the best of a little
more a little different from what you are
used to seeing is
I can show you the model of well,
let's make an example and show what
a mere integrated planning of a
business
is worth, that is, a model that allows a
company to a large company project
from their demands whatever
energy,
gas or whatever it is that they demand see the
logistics of supply see
sales projections the c  These are the
investments in the logistics of
supply and finally collect all
this in a financial model that will allow us to
see what is the
effective contribution that what we are
proposing makes to the business
yes because one of the great themes in the
entire study the machine line
finally  of the data saints that is to say
how much this contributes
to decision making
effectively this is a good thing to
do is it very good or is it not irrelevant
then the idea of ​​power in the same
place is answering those two
questions say eyes doing a
classification process is very  identified
these patterns and these patterns
mean that now the cluster consumes
this and the cluster sees consumes this other and
from that our demand
changes and based on that is what we
are waiting for is what gives it the most value we
can measure the  impact of what we
have just discovered
so that you have an idea models of
this type have, for example, the d channel  In order
to determine its
toll rates for ships, Panama has the
San Pablo distributor to
project its entire business of how much
gas and how many networks it has to extend
to meet its demand.
Cocacola Andina has it here in Córdoba
to do the entire production of its
business.
In short, and a series of other examples, it
supports much more than a demo. It is not the
only thing that I want to convey to you.
Let's follow the example.
In this case, it is a manufacturing company.
In this, in the first graph, what we
are seeing is that it
has a production capacity of  126
million and at a certain moment,
the demand exceeds
the demand exceeds the
production capacity of that company,
so that is where we introduce
different scenarios that can graph
what was happening with these variables
as we introduce, for example, a
new product,
one can simulate  in real time what
happens when you introduce a new product
is fixed on that new product of the  what
appears here is to say here we see what is
the market share that this
new product is going to capture how much it cannibalizes and
even another product where it already
exists because it competes in the same
segment
and we see what happens at the production level
where before we had unattended production
in the year 2020 now that was
ahead of us this year
so you could tell us well what happens
if we don't just launch new products if we do
n't expand production capacity
and run that's all is the
scenario simultaneously
and what we are seeing that  it is the
production capacity
increase in the month that we need and
now our demand can be covered
because the plant has greater capacity
last you have chosen by the scenarios
I think it should be
good we are seeing them all together and it is
good
I have chosen only the increase
of  capacity we have leftovers
ok
fine
if we have something else
we can't show how we install
libraries it
's very technical  yes yes yes but in any
case before moving on to answer
questions inside that we had prepared
to show you
so now
bond girl is there as they say in
brazil of asking questions it
works online
that is it can be installed on premise or
provided as a service the
infrastructure  From the back, in general,
Amazon is preferred
and the configuration of the type of
server according to what you want to use
is also very flexible. You
always need the model from the back
with the card open to be able to
interact with that data. The data is
not alone.  in the client to be able to
be isolated without having this
and they interact in the client's bed it is
a visualizer of what is
happening in this instance it
has some cost it will have it there is a
free forever user as we have put
so that they use it all the time  who
want if naturally there is
infrastructure behind this
then a non commercial version has been released
let's not say they extend p  because
it has all the functionalities but
not commercial to give them more resources and
that they can do more important things
still it is like that it has a cost of 9
dollars per user
ask platforms for android for
them
the help and it is html5 so
naturally it works in any
browser  of this life,
good afternoon, here this connects with
a database or is it just
uploading a csb because I'm interested in knowing
what happens when the data source changes,
how is this updated?
you have
you have pandas here
so with pandas it has a connection with
any database practically
perfect and even what it has is that
we have not seen is the possibility of
managing tasks that you could say well
I have that database and the source
is there but what do I need  that this is
updated every night and then
you generate tasks so that
once a day a certain part of the code
is executed d  The way to update and
have the base ready, thank you,
thank you, ask me about how
the code versions are integrated into
these tools,
and interestingly,
there
are several various topics of the versioned topic,
the first
is where we start with the tree
by the sea,
this every  time, an
administrator user sees a bit of everything,
but
each user has their
own workspace and a public space
thinks that this is within a
company, a corporation, a university,
so there are some
public models that cannot be executed and
probably nobody  it wants you to
touch them on the administrator, it takes care
of updating that and there, but you
always have the possibility to take it to your
own workspace if then
in your workspace you have total freedom
to do what you want with it and
we're on with it  theme of the code each one of
those models one can generate the
different versions I work
as I was generating  a new jupiter
or notebook with the versioned in a b1
b2 b3
as you would like but it can also happen
that two people are working on
the same model simultaneously each
one in their area but simultaneously
then for
that what has what  the plan includes is
the possibility of exporting and importing
the modules, that is, in general we are going to
put that we return to any of the
examples
that one is working in this module and
another in this other module, so each
one can export it is the
administrator who consolidates the  versioned towards the
important one who generates it will
export it to the one who imports and
who imports the one who consolidates the
import and the
integration with git hub is in progress including that
will be the whole issue of versioning further
back speak
but good for him  moment this is what
is
perfect thanks to another query
regarding the one you mentioned
behind that you can use amazon
that integration behind and  s visual here too or
is it dealt with a separate infrastructure team
I don't know if you want to connect or fabián
the architecture
what if the architecture of the
platform was mounted on
amazon when they logged in
because they saw that it took a little while
to get to the first one  first
page at that time I was creating a
virtual machine for each one of Caracas
therefore that gives us
total independence and the possibility of
unlimited growth in resources
perfect thanks
I accept the management and the fork the
orchestration of those of those instances
hello how are you a user  end of the
application in which I am
doing here he needs to have an
account
we are not going to make an application and
share the dashboard to see how
we did here no he is going to click on
that link and he is going to share directly he is
going to access he does not have  that installing nothing
is going to consume it directly,
sorry, I no longer have the bilin model,
which you currently only charge
me  nte by a monthly user as I
said before in the case of companies
also a bilin model according to the
capacity according to the data
processed as well as functions the day
there are several instances especially
depending on the
infrastructure resources that they demand and there is a
enterprise version where it is by type
of user die type there are users in a
company you have users who are
simply older consumers short
higher level users
you have some who are designers of
das yours that is cool there are others
who are the ones who do  modeling and others
who are administrators, then
depending on the mix of types of
users is the cost of licensing
[Music]